a newly appointed military Governor
visits the front
lines Democratic Republic of Congo's
Army has been fighting the M23 armed
group widely understood to be backed by
neighboring
Rwanda Coalition of armed groups called
wazalendo has also been fighting
M23 we have the population on our side
and this is why we are now talking about
the was aando of phenomenon we cannot
deny their existence because they
defending the Integrity of the
country this video filmed by an armed
group shows its Fighters preparing to
attack an M23
position but in the last week M23 is
rapidly grown stronger and advanced
towards the provincial capital of
GMA more than half a million people have
fled their homes since M23 restarted an
old conflict 2 years ago all the armed
groups involved are accused of
atrocities against civilians including
executions and
rape M23 Fighters have been filmed and
photographed carrying weapons over the
border from Rwanda the US and the EU
have sanctioned both Rwandan and
congales individuals for their roles in
the conflict Rwanda denies backing
M23 in this video Fighters show weapons
they say were captured from congales
forces to the National and International
Community
we M23 want dialogue we're not partisans
of War as people
believe every attempt at dialog has
failed Angola's President jaal Lorenzo
who's tried to mediate said M23 is
refusing to withdraw and come to the
table it's the latest round of a
conflict that began in the 1990s when
Rwanda and Uganda invaded Congo and
looted its vast mineral wealth more than
6 million people were killed and there's
been armed conflict here ever since
Malcolm Webb Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer